let's say that i'm working in a
restaurant and i'm making ten dollars
per hour but on top of my hourly wage i
also get tips each hour so this entire
expression you can view this as how much
i might make in a given hour now you
might also realize that the number of
tips or the amount of tips i might make
in an hour can change dramatically from
hour to hour it can vary one hour it
might be lunchtime get a lot of tips
people might get some big ticket items
the next hour might not have any
customers and then my tips might be
really low so the tips part right over
here we consider that the entire word we
consider that to be a variable
from scenario to scenario it can change
so for example
in one scenario maybe it's lunch time
i'm i'm getting really big tips so tips
is equal to let's say it's equal to 30
and so the total amount i might make in
that hour is going to we can go back to
this expression right over here it's
going to be 10
plus instead of writing tips here i'll
write 30 because that's what my tips are
in that hour and so that is going to be
equal to it's going to be equal to 40.
let me do that let me do that yellow
color it's going to be equal to
40. but let's say right after that the
restaurant slows down we're out of the
lunch hour for whatever reason maybe the
restaurant next door has a big sale or
something and so the next hour my tips
go down dramatically my tips go down to
five dollars for that hour
now i go back to this expression the
total i make is my hourly wage plus the
five dollars in tips
plus the five dollars in dips which is
equal to fifteen dollars as you see this
entire expression the ten plus tips it
changed depending on what the value of
the variable tips is
now you won't see whole words typically
used in algebra as variables we get lazy
and so instead we tend to use just
easier to write symbols and so in this
context we instead of writing tips maybe
we could have just written
plus t
where t where t represents the tips that
we get in an hour and so then we would
say okay what happens when t is equal to
30. well if t is equal to 30 then we'd
have if let me write so what happens
when t is equal to 30 well then we have
a situation t is equal to 30 this
evaluates to 10 plus 30 which would be
40. what would happen if t is equal to 5
well then this would evaluate to 10 plus
which is equal to 15. now i want to be
clear we didn't even have to use t we
didn't even really have to use a letter
although in traditional algebra you
almost do use a letter we could have
written that as we could have written it
as 10 plus x
where x is your tips per hour x might
not be as natural it's not the first
letter in the word tips or you could
have even written
10 plus you could have even written 10
plus star where you could say star
represents the number of tips in an hour
but it just might have not made as much
intuitive sense but hopefully this gives
you a general idea of just what a
variable is all it is is a symbol all it
is is a symbol that represents different
that a symbol that represents varying
values and that's why we call it a
variable